First and foremost, an email must be understandable.
Therefore, the simpler, the better.
To allow the recipient to organize his inbox,...
...the "Subject" box must say what the message is about.
Only attach necessary files.
Keep your sentences and paragraphs short; no more than five lines.
Don't try to impress with big words, but use easy vocabulary and structures.
Don't SHOUT by using ALL CAPS (capital letters).
To highlight a word, use asterisks.
Abbreviations like btw (by the way), asap (as soon as possible)...
...and brgds (best regards) are generally understood.
Take a look at this sample.
Dear John Smith,...
...The reason I am writing is...
...your name was given to me by...
...this is just to let you know that...
...I look forward to hearing from you.
If you need any further information, please do not hesitate to contact us.